ronde où l'ong verte ou rouge paumés ou
en feuilles douce amère ou piquant
chacune contribuer à la salade par sa
saveur et son croquant sur le marché
maintenant on trouve vraiment une
variété de laitue impressionnant une
formation aussi on n'est pas trop
aventureux on va rester dans la sbm
ghoul à boston on à la fameuse est la
roquette
est-ce que ça goûte la cat et moi c'est
moi
noisette aussi un peu piqué puis on est
la fameuse hand et et leur a dit que si
on aime l'amertume complètement en
première proposition d'isabelle une
laitue iceberg avec raisin et pacanes
route on de pain noir
radi et oignons les fêtes une vie des
quatre maisons au lait beurre j'écris du
beurre vieux-bourg 10% au niveau pas
beau du tout où on peut le remplacer par
la crème ce jus de citron un peu de miel
poids puis des années on voit tout 5
beaucoup beaucoup de négrette sal alosi
l'alarmé c'est juste pour la bonne chère
peut dire formé de las vegas et on veut
pas l'enrobé
et justement veut laisser la place aux
lexus du brouillard le québec produit
100 mille tonnes de laitue par année que
ce soit dans les sandwiches en entrée ou
en entre eux mais on en mangerait près
de dix kilos chacun fait le bambin
discothèque que deux choix romaine ou
bostons match ou chicorée feuilles de
chêne épinards et rocket jusqu'à la
magnifique salanova dont c'était la
première récolte de l'année le 1er juin
dernier dans les terres noires de
sherrington t2 voter là c'est de
salanova la fin rouge et de la feuille
verte
c'est un peu différent de l'élite
mettons enfin louis hydroponique
au fond il ya plus les tissus sont plus
gros plus c'est plus nourrissants
[Musique]
les laitues des chansons coupé et
nettoyer une a eu un petit jet d'eau
chlorée qui va nettoyer le trompe les
faits ensuite après tant d aller par
alors personnes de partout ça va être un
duo a foncé dans des grosses bois est
mis sur des palettes à tanger un livre
au chakra la planète qui la met dans une
remorque lara moore 48 vols a livré à
luzay nous envoler à refroidir les
produits ont appelé un chat les cellules
sont un peu plus robustes sont moins
gorgé d'eau le soleil aussi avec la
photosynthèse fait un saut qui sont
siennes une finale à la durée de vie est
meilleure
comme la salle à nova pouces en pleine
terre elle doit être relevée à la maison
le radio pour un peu d'amertume
les pousses de tournesol mélange varié
de jeunes feuilles
les médecins ont été mis de l'avant par
les chefs il ya plusieurs années
on les trouve maintenant partout en
épicerie on est prêt pour récolter sa
tête une horloge
aujourd'hui et demain c'est la fenêtre
de récolte dans l'île et tu à croissance
rapide ou les épinards
on a une fenêtre de récolte assez
restreint de demain de journée
internationale est le plus gros
producteur de légumes frais au canada
donc on fait une bb caleçon veut une
feuille qui qui plus tendre un peu
qu'une qu'une qu'elle matures sinon les
feuilles avec un beauty look que des
boues rouges éclateur avec des lettres
ouvertes sont très populaires pour le
mélange mesclun
[Musique]
grâce aux nouvelles techniques
d'emballage pour la conservation
il est facile d'en garder à la maison la
barre caire n'a vraiment rebondir dans
un briseur le pro du gardon
tessa paris renvoie sans cesse à 15 %
par année
c'est ainsi on sent environ un million
deux cent mille
millions 500 mille d'arcade par semaine
la saison est courte au québec mais il
faut remplir des barquettes toute
l'année en floride
on est ce que l'on sache jamais né
vous faites aujourd'hui
bah en fait la régulant ont fait défaut
santé c'est qu'en soit la bataille
comment s'adresse à celles
rodez
la vraie règle c'est la chaîne de front
conservez max moreau
sur la terre sainte
c'est traîner sur la contre le foie
c'est là
on embête des grades si ma foi sont ce
des morceaux de bacon
ce sont des morceaux de bacon vinaigre
de cidre avec une moutarde à l'ancienne
on ajoute des pommes et des noisettes
qu'on construit
et du fromage huile atome de kamouraska
a vraiment ce que j'adore le mélange de
couleurs de saveurs de textures reste et
de croc qu'un pour s'amuser avec les
salles à la clé c'est que ce soit
ludique à wayne est gourmand je voyais
venir
ça c'est la nouvelle façon de manger la
sandale à mains nues on l'entend
craquant